but we play now with Moore's out Barrett
nice fun wide open is packing for three
Bharat scoots inside supplement of a
barge a baron
that's a huge basket Oh big he's two
hoots war because Washington came all
the way back that comes Randall Randall
on past a ferret
excellent defense from militina good
ball handling from rent this is what I
mean I didn't know Randall had this type
of handles crossover drives the lane
drops the dime not out of control
Barrett knows how to finish defensively
he really defends the rim foul once
again Jake Barrett what a third quarter
with a rookie man with guys hanging all
over him finishes around the basket
making plays that's it that's Payton out
of solid game on Monday as did bear
especially in the second half but just
changes to the right hand and lays it up
and in for his first bucket of the
Guardians if Smith is playing this is
his 10th year his eleventh different
team Clyde Barrett again inside looks
off to an auspicious start penetrating
creating off the glass from the same
housing area
since my piece of it he still isn't all
eight tenths of a second ginseng six and
LM very six seven
Marge a the leaders cups of ten
they say he's all lefty but look at the
right hand this time as he wheels and
deals an impact and how his life has
changed from Vince sanity in Toronto to
the elder statesman nice take there by a
young RJ Barrett Barrett saw to steal
the whole way
finally Brando Randall gathers and
finishes to the turnover but let's watch
our Jay Baer jump the passing lane I
love this mindset
great job by Randall hands need to be
looking at the gather directly it's two
steps after the gather and the gather
occurs twenty can control the ball
enough to the passer shooter three
single night
and I think Marcus Morris who was the
epitome of consistency they will look at
a fast-break right so why is he fan in
the corner and you want to say well you
are right the open layup still is more
efficient than the corner three as
Robinson eats the alley Robinson comes
off just gets himself right to the cup
and throw this high pass right there's
one guy in the gym young on the drive
good hands from Dennis Smith
on the break RJ Baron raisiny
[Applause]
I'm out from David Tisdale now they're
playing off their defense which gets me
RJ out in front easy finish there's a
tribe in by Paris with the rebound
pulled down by Bobby Portis who started
behind at center they go inside in the
banks my parents what we came here by
Barry recognized the big man's on the
perimeter couple dribbles on the deck
then we get all the way to the hole and
on the flipside that fight on the
streets of Boston one time and there was
[Applause]
an Archie bear cutting hard cuts down
the nice finish without an injury and
staff wants to play
Battery Park goes on banks don't take
away that left in
[Applause]
did he struggle from the outside this
preseason but can access or have a lot
of horses to go into battle with in one
or two Hammer town high spirits watch
this by Randall
another big passing out of the boats go
appreciate and the NBA fans that are
watching to really appreciate your
honesty and the other way Big Jim why
knocks leapfrog any of those players to
scratch at that number eight shot in the
Eastern Conference Candice RJ parrot
takes it in hi what's up you guys this
Taylor Brooks with bleacher report make
sure that you subscribe for some more
video content